[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui bienvenue à faire à l'autochtone 6
mai sa mort lundi puis j'imagine que si
vous avez peu de cash et un trou d'une
roche dans les dernières semaines
vous avez vu passer aussi dans les
médias dans les médias sociaux ce qui
vraiment attiré mon attention cette
semaine c'est à dire tout le débat
autour du partage sur les territoires
autochtones et non autochtones des
ressources naturelles et
particulièrement des ressources la
biodiversité et là je parle est
particulièrement des conflits qui
existent entre la communauté de la
nation cp cnac tic et la communauté de
saunier ville en nouvelle écosse en ce
qui entoure la pêche au homard et aussi
par exemple par rapport au moratoire sur
le rial qui existent aussi présentement
dans le parc de la vérendrye qui a été
mis en place par la communauté
anishinabe elles vont dire donc pourquoi
est ce que je veux parler de ça parce
que c'est pas la seule
le sel instance de conflits qui existent
on pense encore aujourd'hui à tout ce
qui touche la nation web souhaitait
d'ailleurs salah des grands relents de
la nation ou et souhaitait de la
mobilisation des nations où elle
souhaitait qu'on a vu cette image avant
le confinement tous que vides et
pourquoi
et bien parce qu'on parle de droits
ancestraux autochtone on parle de droit
qui sont reconnus aussi par la cour
suprême est là présentement jeu quand je
parle de la pêche aux morts je pensais à
l'arrêt marshall qui a reconnu le droit
aux communautés autochtones de pouvoir
pêcher ou chassés pour une vie une vie
et commerces modeste et là encore une
fois c'est comment on définit qu'est ce
qu'ils aient une vie modeste que ce qui
est gagné sa vie pour un autochtone
quand c'est un briquet dans des concepts
nord-américain dans des concepts
coloniaux mais par exemple qui sont
reconnus par la constitution canadienne
us et qu'est-ce que ça amène comme
conflit présentement c'est assez clair
des codes des violences physiques sur
les pêcheurs big man il ya des cas
d'agression c'est à dire on va voir les
pêcheurs traditionnels qui sont
présentement sur l'eau avant l'ouverture
de la saison officielle des pêcheurs
commercial et commerciaux ce climat et
on voit que des pêcheurs commerciaux ont
encerclé le bateau de pêcheurs
traditionnels vont couper les cases et
prendre les cases de pêche au homard des
chasseurs mig ma il ya énormément
d'agressivité il ya énormément aussi de
commenter extrêmement violent a ling et
pourquoi est ce que c'est une
problématique s'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ignorent encore que ses droits le
fort connus et même présentement il ya
un appel à des associations de pêche
d'enlever ses droits reconnus là-haut
communauté autochtone et je veux que
vous remonter très loin aussi dans les
années 70 c'est pour voir que ce
débat-là existe depuis longtemps et
qu'on en ait utilisé les idéologies de
la conservation pour empêcher les
communautés autochtones de pouvoir
pêcher ou châssis sur leur propre
territoire
présentement on soutient que les 50 la
cinquantaine de pêcheurs mig mas va
détruire la subsistance
comment alors qu'ils ont eux mêmes leurs
propres quotas de pêche
ils ont leur propre système en place
mais qui est gérée par la communauté
mouvement messe est dite conservation là
est vraiment pousser de l'avant par les
pêcheurs commerciaux qui sont beaucoup
plus nombreux et qui pêche beaucoup plus
que et communaux d'énigmes cependant
quand on voit aussi quand c'est au tour
de la communauté autochtone de demander
un arrêt de la pêche audrey de la chasse
puis le jeu penche présentement aux
algonquins qui sont dans le parc la
vérendrye et qui essayent de demande un
moratoire sur l'orignal pour lui laisser
une place de repos puisque les chasse
ont été de moins en moins fructueuse
biais là c'est le contraire c'est qu'on
nous empêchera pas d'accéder à notre
réunion nous empêchera pas d'être des
chasseurs d'avoir notre viande
alors certains idéologies qui ont été
posées par la colonisation comme déposée
par la suprématie de certains groupes
sont utilisés pour ou contre les droits
de pêche des chasseurs et des pêcheurs
et ça c'est extrêmement prometteur je
sais que ce poteau non tu as envie de
lire l'arrêt marche mais c'est
extrêmement intéressant et de lire aussi
les arrêts qui concerne les droits
ancestraux puisque ce sont des droits
qui sont jugés comme par coop à ce que
chaque nation a pas accès aux mêmes
droits ancestraux selon le territoire
d'où qu'ils viennent
donc moi je ne suis pas une mine mois
pêcheuse de homard mais on a une pêche
des homards quand même qui existe chez
lise nous cependant le droit de
l'échangé commercial et social aux que
la problématique vient pas et c'est
beaucoup
les pêcheurs commercial c'est le droit à
l échange commercial qui existent pour
des nations comme les micmacs qui
faisait des échanges commerciales de
pêche avec les autres nations
autochtones ou par exemple les mois qui
faisaient des échanges commerciales avec
les autres nations
qu'est ce qui a trait au thabor humain
est donc cette présence dans l'économie
commerciale vraiment dérange on n'a pas
de problème quand on pêche aux poissons
coraux chasse un animal même encore ça
dérange beaucoup
surya c'est à dire mais quand il ya un
apport par rapport à
capacité de vivre dans un milieu
commercial à valeur notre identité
autochtone devient vraiment très
passéiste et on peut pas imaginer qu'un
échange et comme je suis en transe
transmission commerciale qui peut se
faire en nation cependant il ya toujours
la responsabilité qui vient avec les
changes qui vient avec la cueillette sur
le territoire la chasse la pêche
toutes les nations selon leurs codes
culturels leur cote de nations ont une
responsabilité à respecter la capacité
du territoire à se régénérer donc
cependant c'est très difficile de les
faire accepter par l'ensemble du public
ou par le gouvernement est présentement
bien on voit certains pêcheurs vouloir
prendre la place des agents des pêches
et océans vouloir prendre même des
places de policiers alors que des fois
même la police est pas totalement actif
pour empêcher des actes de violence
envers et énormément de problématiques
présentement se passe dans les deux
camps mais particulièrement envers les
corps des cadets communauté autochtone
alors je vous inviterai à suivre à
suivre ce qui se passe chez les minimes
à ce qui se passe chez les algonquins
celle qui se passe chez les les
communautés web souhaitant parce que ce
sont des enjeux canadien cependant avec
des droits autochtones parce qu'il faut
pas oublier que c'est droit autochtone
existe encore depuis le début de la
colonisation jusqu'à aujourd'hui ils
sont extrêmement intéressants mais il
amène énormément de périodes de
contention docteur des notes et là on
voit beaucoup de communautés essayer de
travailler en cogestion pour le
territoire
et souvent c'est là qu'on va voir un
avancement beaucoup plus éclairées par
rapport à intégrer les savoirs
ancestraux dans la gestion du territoire
des ressources d'avoir une relation qui
est beaucoup plus équilibré beaucoup
plus respectueuse en deux nations qui
ont des frictions assez
assez souvent quand c'est une question
de cueillette sur le téléphone donc
n'hésitez pas à vous renseigner sur la
question parce qu'elle est extrêmement
large et pas encore très connue du
public
il sait pas non plus à partager ce pays
je vous souhaite une belle semaine